♪
7♪
>> GOOD MORNING EVERYONE!
GOOD MORNING DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUES AND GRADUATES.
GREETINGS TO ALL OF YOU JOINING
US FROM AROUND THE WORLD
ONLINE.
I AM LYNN COOLEY, DEAN OF YALE
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES.
WE ARE CELEBRATING ON THE
GROUNDS OF OLD CAMPUS THIS
MORNING.
PLEASE ALLOW ME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES AND NATIONS,
INCLUDING MOHEGAN, MASHANTUCKET
PEQUOT, EASTERN PEQUOT,
SCHAGHTICOKE, GOLDEN HILL
PAUGUSSETT, NIANTIC, THE
QUINNIPIAC AND OTHER ALGONQUIAN
SPEAKING PEOPLES, WHO HAVE,
THROUGH COUNTLESS GENERATIONS
BEFORE US, STEWARDED THE LANDS
AND WATERWAYS OF WHAT IS NOW
THE
CONNECTICUT.
WE HONOR AND RESPECT THE
ENDURING RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN THESE PEOPLES
AND
NATIONS, AND THIS LAND.
WELCOME TO THE 2021
COMMENCEMENT
FOR THE YALE GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
ARTS AND SCIENCES.
THIS YEAR'S CEREMONY CANNOT BE
LIKE PREVIOUS ONES IN THE 160
YEARS OF YALE GRADUATE SCHOOL
COMMENCEMENTS. WE ARE FORTUNATE
TO BE ABLE TO GATHER AS WE
EMERGE FROM A GLOBAL PANDEMIC,
BUT WE CAN ONLY SHARE OUR
PROCEEDINGS REMOTELY WITH OUR
FAMILIES, FRIENDS, AND
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. WHETHER YOU ARE HERE
IN NEW HAVEN, OR ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE WORLD, WE JOIN
TOGETHER IN HONORING THE
PERSISTENCE, RESILIENCE AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, OF THE CLASS
OF
2021. TO THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS OF OUR GRADUATES WHO
ARE
WATCHING, WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE POWERFUL INSPIRATION AND
SUPPORT THAT YOU HAVE PROVIDED
OUR STUDENTS THROUGH THE YEARS
TO THIS GREAT DAY. NEAR OR FAR,
WE ARE ALL PART OF THIS
CELEBRATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY DEEP
ADMIRATION AND GRATITUDE TO THE
UNIVERSITY LEADERSHIP, FACULTY,
STUDENTS, AND STAFF WHO CAME
TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY TO
CONTINUE THE WORK OF THE
UNIVERSITY DURING THIS
DIFFICULT
YEAR. THANK YOU PRESIDENT
SALOVEY AND PROVOST STROBEL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP, KEEPING US AS
SAFE AND PRODUCTIVE AS POSSIBLE
EVEN WHILE THE WORLD WAS
UPENDED.
JOINING PRESIDENT SALOVEY,
PROVOST STROBEL, AND THE DEANS
OF THE GRADUATE SCHOOL HERE ON
THE STAGE ARE SOME OTHER
REMARKABLE PEOPLE:
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE GRADUATE
MENTOR AWARDS.
THEY EXEMPLIFY THE RANGE,
TALENT, AND DEDICATION OF OUR
FACULTY. NOMINATED BY THE
STUDENTS, GRADUATE MENTOR
AWARDS
RECOGNIZE PROFESSORS WHO ARE
EXCEPTIONAL
IN FOSTERING THE INTELLECTUAL,
PROFESSIONAL, AND PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR STUDENTS. IN
THE PAST YEAR, MORE THAN EVER,
THE STRAIN OF THE PANDEMIC
BROUGHT INTO SHARP FOCUS THAT
THE ESSENTIAL CORE OF GRADUATE
EDUCATION IS ACTIVE MENTORING.
THE TIME-HONORED
STUDENT-FACULTY
PARTNERSHIP FINDS ITS EXEMPLARS
IN THESE INSPIRED TEACHERS.
PLEASE RING YOUR BELLS, I THINK
HAVE YOU THEM, FOR:
JENNIFER RAAB,
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN THE
HISTORY OF ART WHO COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY;
GARY BRUDVIG,
BENJAMIN SILLIMAN
PROFESSOR OF CHEMISTRY;
AND KELLY SHUE,
PROFESSOR OF FINANCE.
[  BELLS RINGING ]
OKAY.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
ALSO JOINING US TODAY ARE THE
STUDENT MARSHALS WHO PROCESSED
INTO OLD CAMPUS WITH US,
LUCYLLE ARMENTANO,
SOON TO BE A PH.D. IN
PSYCHOLOGY
AND STEPHEN GAUGHRAN, PH.D.,
ECOLOGY AND EVOLUTIONARY
BIOLOGY.
BOTH ARE PAST CHAIRS OF
THE GRADUATE STUDENT ASSEMBLY.
LUCY AND STEPHEN WERE INSPIRED
LEADERS OF THE GSA AND
THOUGHTFUL PARTNERS WITH ME AND
OTHERS ON CAMPUS AS WE
CONTINUALLY SEEK TO IMPROVE
GRADUATE EDUCATION AT YALE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EXEMPLARY
SERVICE DURING YOUR TIME IN
OFFICE AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR GRADUATION.
[  BELLS RINGING ]
YEAH, THAT'S OKAY.
AND NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY,
CHRIS ARGYRIS,
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHOLOGY, TO
DELIVER HIS REMARKS TO YOU.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY?
>> THANK YOU, DEAN COOLEY.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF YOU
GRADUATING TODAY.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE A FEW WORDS WITH
YOU.
SO GRADUATIONS ARE IMPORTANT
MILESTONES, NO MATTER WHEN THEY
TAKE PLACE.
BUT YOUR GRADUATION WILL ALWAYS
BE EXCEPTIONAL.
FOR OVER A YEAR WE HAVE WALKED
A STRANGE AND HISTORIC PATH
TOGETHER.
WE'RE NOW AT THE END OF AN
ACADEMIC YEAR LIKE NO OTHER,
BUT ALTHOUGH OUR TRADITIONS MAY
LOOK DIFFERENT THIS YEAR,
THEY'RE JUST AS MEANINGFUL AS
EVER.
COMMENCEMENT IS A TIME OF
CELEBRATION.
IT'S A CHANCE FOR YOU TO REVEL
IN YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BUT IT'S ALSO A TIME, AN
OPPORTUNITY, TO REFLECT AND SAY
THANK YOU.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PART
OF YOUR JOURNEY TO THIS MOMENT,
AND I HOPE YOU WILL FIND TIME
TO TELL THEM HOW MUCH THEY HAVE
MEANT TO YOU.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU TO YOU.
DAY AFTER DAY, FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR, YOU'VE MADE SACRIFICES
FOR THE GREATER GOOD.
YOU'VE STUDIED, CONDUCTED
RESEARCH, WORKED UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY CONDITIONS.
YOU'VE HELPED KEEP OUR
NEIGHBORS ON CAMPUS AND IN NEW
HAVEN SAFE.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS BEEN EASY.
LIKE PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD,
YOU'VE EXPERIENCED LOSS, GRIEF,
UNCERTAINTY.
AND YET YOU HAVE REPAID OUR
COMMUNITY'S TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN YOU MANY TIMES
OVER.
NOW, AS YOU LOOK TO THE FUTURE,
TO YOUR LIVES BEYOND YALE, AND
HOPEFULLY BEYOND THIS MOMENT, I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A PERSONAL
STORY.
IT'S A STORY ABOUT MY PAST AND
MY PRESENT, BUT I SHARE IT
BECAUSE I HOPE IT WILL SHED
SOME LIGHT ON YOUR FUTURE.
IT'S ABOUT TEACHERS AND THE
GIFTS THEY GIVE US.
SO IN THE EARLY 1970s, I WAS A
STUDENT AT WILLIAMSVILLE HIGH
SCHOOL NORTH, OUTSIDE OF
BUFFALO, NEW YORK.
ANYBODY ELSE FROM BUFFALO HERE
TODAY?
WE'RE NOT PRODUCING ENOUGH
GRADUATE STUDENTS AT YALE.
I CAN SEE THAT.
WELL, WILLIAMSVILLE HIGH SCHOOL
NORTH WAS A PRETTY TYPICAL,
LARGE PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL.
WE HAD A POPULAR FOOTBALL TEAM
AND A MARCHING BAND THAT PLAYED
AT THE GAMES.
PERHAPS IT WILL SURPRISE YOU TO
LEARN THAT I DIDN'T PLAY ON THE
FOOTBALL TEAM.
BUT I DID MARCH WITH THE BAND.
AND YOU MIGHT WONDER HOW I FIT
INTO THIS KIND OF A SCHOOL.
WELL, I ACTUALLY EARNED A
VARSITY LETTER, FOR THE DRAMA
CLUB.
BUT I WAS PART OF ANOTHER
STUDENT ORGANIZATION AS WELL.
A POETRY CLUB, HOSTED BY TWO
BELOVED ENGLISH TEACHERS, MR.
AND MRS. BLAZEDALE.
A GROUP OF US WOULD GO TO THEIR
HOME AND SHARE POEMS WE HAD
WRITTEN OR COME ACROSS.
WE DRANK COFFEE AND TALKED
ABOUT POETRY.
IT WAS ALL VERY GROWN-UP.
ESPECIALLY FOR KIDS LIKE US
FROM BUFFALO.
OUR TEACHERS WERE ONLY IN THEIR
20s, MAYBE EARLY 30s, BUT THEY
WERE SOPHISTICATED ADULTS, AND
THEREFORE SEEMED MUCH OLDER TO
US.
THEY CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
LITERATURE, WRITING, POETRY.
BUT MOST OF ALL, THEY CARED
ABOUT US.
THEIR STUDENTS.
IN FACT, I'M NOT THE ONLY
STUDENT OF THE BLAZEDALES ON
THE FACULTY HERE AT YALE.
THEY TAUGHT ENGLISH TO
CHEMISTRY PROFESSOR SCOTT
MILLER ABOUT A DECADE AFTER ME.
FAST FORWARD 46 YEARS.
THE KIDS FROM THAT POETRY CLUB
NOW HAVE FAMILIES AND CAREERS
OF THEIR OWN.
THE SURPRISING NUMBER OF THEM
ARE NOW COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS.
WE'VE STAYED IN TOUCH.
BUT USUALLY WE ONLY SEE EACH
OTHER EVERY FEW YEARS AT BEST.
AS A WAY OF COPING WITH THE
SOCIAL ISOLATION OF THE
PANDEMIC, WE STARTED MEETING
OVER ZOOM.
WE SHARED POEMS, ONCE AGAIN.
WE DRANK COFFEE TOGETHER, ONCE
AGAIN.
OUR FORMER ENGLISH TEACHERS
FROM WILLIAMSVILLE NORTH, NOW
RETIRED, JOINED US.
AND WE FOUND IN THE MIDST OF SO
MUCH GRIEF AND LONELINESS, A
WAY TO CONNECT.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR YOU?
FIRST, MY HOPE FOR EACH OF YOU
IS THAT YOU HAVE MADE A FRIEND
HERE, PERHAPS A FEW FRIENDS,
WHO WILL BE THERE FOR YOU IN 46
YEARS.
THAT'S NO SMALL THING.
SECOND, I HOPE YOU'VE FOUND
GREAT TEACHERS AND MENTORS WHO
WILL CONTINUE TO ADVISE AND
GUIDE YOU FOR YEARS TO COME.
AND THIRD, I HOPE YOU ARE
LEAVING YALE READY TO BECOME
THOSE TEACHERS AND MENTORS TO
THE NEXT GENERATION.
I RECENTLY HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
INTERVIEWING THE POET LO
LOUIS GLICK.
SHE HAS TAUGHT AT YALE SINCE
2004.
SHE TOLD ME SHE THINKS OF
TEACHING AS A WAY OF REPAYING
HER DEBTS.
YOU CAN'T THANK YOUR TEACHERS,
SHE SAID, EXCEPT BY PERFORMING
AS THEY DID FOR ANOTHER
GENERATION.
NOT ALL OF YOU WILL BE
EDUCATORS, OF COURSE.
BUT YOU CAN ALL REPAY YOUR
TEACHERS BY SHARING YOUR
CURIOSITY AND LOVE OF LEARNING
WITH THE WORLD.
YOU CAME TO YALE BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO ASK QUESTIONS AND
SEARCH FOR ANSWERS.
YOU HAVE EARNED MASTER'S
DEGREES OR PH.D.s AND YOU WILL
TAKE YOUR EXPERTISE INTO
UNIVERSITIES, LABORATORIES AND
OTHER WORKPLACES THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD.
ALL OF YOU ARE LEAVING HERE
WITH GIFTS FROM YOUR TEACHERS.
WHAT ARE THESE GIFTS?
FROM MY TEACHERS I LEARNED HOW
TO ASK DIFFERENT QUESTIONS.
BIGGER QUESTIONS.
IN HIGH SCHOOL I WAS ALWAYS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT A
POEM WAS ABOUT.
I WANTED TO UNLOCK THE SECRET
MEANING.
BUT MR. BLAZEDALE WOULD TELL
ME, PETER, WHAT THE POEM IS
ABOUT IS NOT ALWAYS THE MOST
INTERESTING QUESTION.
HE ENCOURAGED ME TO APPRECIATE
BEAUTY AND OCCASIONALLY PUT
ASIDE ANALYSIS.
HE PUSHED ME TO USE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF MY MIND AND MY
EMOTIONS.
TEACHERS THROUGHOUT MY LIFE,
INCLUDING MY PROFESSORS IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL HERE AT YALE IN
THE EARLY 1980s, SHARED WITH ME
THEIR DEEP AND JOYFUL LOVE OF
Y
LEARNING.
THEY MODELED CURIOSITY AND
RESILIENCE.
THEY INTRODUCED ME TO INTERESTS
THAT HAVE MADE MY LIFE RICHER.
AND MORE REWARDING.
IT IS NOW YOUR TIME TO SERVE AS
A MODEL FOR THE NEXT GENERATION
OF SCHOLARS, PRACTITIONERS, AND
PROFESSIONALS.
THAT IS HOW WE REPAY OUR
TEACHERS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE HAVE
LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT OURSELVES
AND ABOUT WHAT WE ARE CAPABLE
OF.
WE'VE BEEN REMINDED AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
THAT WE MUST KEEP LEARNING.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE NEW
CHALLENGES TO TACKLE.
UNEXPECTED PROBLEMS TO SOLVE.
WE'LL HAVE TO PIVOT AND ADAPT.
AND IF WE LOVE LEARNING, IF WE
ARE CURIOUS ABOUT THE WORLD AND
THE PEOPLE IN IT, THEN THE TASK
WILL BE SO MUCH EASIER.
AND MORE FULFILLING.
IN THE BOOK "TUESDAYS WITH
MOREY" THE SPORTS WRITER
DESCRIBES CONNECTING WITH MAURY
SCHWARTZ.
HE'S SUFFERING WITH ALS.
THE BOOK IS AN EXTENDED
REFLECTION ON LIFE AND DEATH.
BUT IT IS ALSO ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A STUDENT
AND HIS TEACHER.
AT THE END, ALBUM SAYS, HAVE
YOU EVER REALLY HAD A TEACHER?
ONE WHO SAW YOU AS A RAW BUT
PRECIOUS THING, A JEWEL THAT
WITH WISDOM COULD BE POLISHED
TO A PROUD SHINE.
IF YOU ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO FIND
YOUR WAY TO SUCH TEACHERS, YOU
WILL ALWAYS FIND YOUR WAY BACK.
I HOPE YOU FIND YOUR WAY BACK.
BACK TO YOUR TEACHERS, BACK TO
YALE.
I HOPE YOU WILL RETURN TO
CAMPUS AND WALK DOWN
CHAPE
CHAPEL STREET AND ENJOY THE
SUNSHINE OR THE SNOW.
ON THE OLD CAMPUS, ON THE NEW
HUMANITIES QUADRANGLE ON
SCIENCE HILL.
I HOPE YOU WILL FIND THE JOY OF
DISCOVERY WITH OTHERS.
I HOPE YOU SHARE YOUR CURIOSITY
WITH THE WORLD THAT NEEDS
QUESTIONS AS MUCH AS ANSWERS.
A WORLD THAT NEEDS LIGHT AND
TRUTH MORE THAN EVER.
I USUALLY CONCLUDE MY ADDRESSES
ON COMMENCEMENT WEEKEND WITH A
FEW WORDS OF VERSE.
AFTER ALL, I WAS IN THE POETRY
CLUB AT WILLIAMSVILLE NORTH.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE READ
ELIZABETH ALEXANDER, BILLY
COLLINS, CLAUDIA RANKIN.
BUT MOST OFTEN I'VE TURNED TO
THE WORDS OF JOHN MILTON FROM
"PARADISE LOST."
YOU KNOW, THOSE VERSES ABOUT
LEAVING THE GARDEN OF EDEN WITH
WANDERING STEPS AND SLOW, AND
MAKING ONE'S WAY INTO A WORLD
THAT IS ALL BEFORE YOU.
THE MOMENTS WHEN THOSE LINES
MOVE TO ME TEARS.
IN THIS CHALLENGING YEAR
THOUGH, PARADISE CERTAINLY DOES
NOT SEEM LIKE THE RIGHT
METAPHOR FOR OUR BELOVED
CAMPUS.
BUT I LOOK AHEAD.
WITH GREAT OPTIMISM.
AND I TRUST YOU DO TOO.
SO PERHAPS THESE WORDS OF EMILY
DICKINSON SEEM MORE APPROPRIATE
AT THIS MOMENT "HOPE IS A THING
WITH FEATHERS THAT PERCHES IN
THE SOUL, SINGS THE TUNE
WITHOUT THE WORDS AND NEVER
STOPS AT ALL."
MY FRIENDS, YOU ARE READY TO
FACE THE FUTURE WITH OPTIMISM
AND DETERMINATION.
YOU ARE READY TO REPAY THE
GIFTS YOUR MENTORS HAVE GIVEN
YOU.
AND SHARE THE JOY OF DISCOVERY
WITH OTHERS.
YOU GO WITH OUR BEST WISHES AND
OUR ADMIRATION.
STUDENTS OF THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
OF ARTS AND SCIENCES,
CONGRATULATIONS AND GOOD LUCK!
[  BELLS RINGING ]
>> THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
SALOVEY,
FOR BEING HERE WITH US TODAY
AND FOR YOUR WISE WORDS AND
POETRY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER --
WE'VE SAID THAT MANY TIMES THIS
YEAR, RIGHT?
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER AT A
GRADUATE SCHOOL COMMENCEMENT,
WE
HAVE A KEYNOTE SPEAKER, THE
REMARKABLE PROFESSOR AKIKO
IWASAKI.
SHE IS A DISTINGUISHED SCIENCE
AND KEY FIGURE IN
COVID-19 RESEARCH WHOSE WORK
FOCUSES ON THE MECHANISMS OF
IMMUNE DEFENSE AGAINST VIRUSES.
AMONG HER MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
HER
LAB DEVELOPED A NEW VACCINE
STRATEGY CALLED ‘PRIME AND
PULL'
THAT CAN BE USED TO TREAT THOSE
ALREADY INFECTED WITH A VIRUS,
UNLIKE VACCINES THAT ARE GIVEN
PREVENTATIVELY. AMONG HER
CURRENT PROJECTS, PROFESSOR
IWASAKI IS DIRECTING A TEAM
INVESTIGATING THE ROLE OF
IMMUNE
RESPONSE IN COVID-19
LONG-HAULERS AND DISCOVERING
THAT THE EFFECTS OF THE VACCINE
ARE BENEFICIAL IN ALLEVIATING
PERSISTENT HEALTH ISSUES CAUSED
BY THE VIRUS. IF YOU ARE NOT
AWARE OF HER REPUTATION IN
MEDICAL, SCIENTIFIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH RESEARCH, YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD OR SEEN HER IN
THE NEWS AS SHE IS REGULARLY
TAPPED BY MAJOR NEWS MEDIA TO
DISCUSS HER WORK AND TO HELP
THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTAND THE LATEST
PANDEMIC-RELATED RESEARCH. SHE
HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS
AND
HONORS, INCLUDING ELECTION TO
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES
IN 2018, AND TO THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF MEDICINE IN 2019.
IT IS AN HONOR TO HAVE HER HERE
TO TALK WITH US TODAY. PLEASE
WELCOME PROFESSOR AKIKO
IWASAKI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[  BELLS RINGING ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DEAN
COOLEY FOR THE KIND
INTRODUCTION.
IT IS MY GREAT HONOR TO BE
STANDING HERE TODAY, TO
CELEBRATE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF
ALL OF YOU WHO ARE GRADUATING
WITH A DEGREE FROM YALE
UNIVERSITY TODAY.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY
RECOGNIZING AND THANKING THE
NUMEROUS PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED
EACH OF YOU TODAY, SO THAT YOU
CAN BE HERE TO DEVOTE
YOURSELVES INTO THE STUDIES OF
YOUR
MASTER'S AND PH.D. LET US THANK
THAT SOMEONE IN YOUR LIFE,
WHETHER IT BE YOUR FAMILY,
TEACHERS, PARTNERS, FRIENDS OR
NEIGHBORS.
YOU HAVE MADE IT!
THE PAST FEW YEARS HAVE NOT
BEEN
EASY FOR ANYONE. YOU HAVE
ENDURED THE COVID PANDEMIC AND
PERSEVERED IN YOUR STUDIES.
SOME
OF YOU HAVE LOST YOUR LOVED
ONES, AND WERE UNABLE TO BE
WITH
YOUR FAMILY IN TIMES OF NEED.
MANY INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS WERE UNABLE TO RETURN
TO THEIR HOMES, TO BE THERE FOR
YOUR FAMILIES DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. JUST KNOW HOW
PROUD THEY ARE OF YOU TODAY. TO
SEE YOU GRADUATING WITH A
DEGREE
FROM ONE OF THE FINEST
INSTITUTIONS IN THE COUNTRY.
THE PANDEMIC WASN'T THE ONLY
TURMOIL WE FACED. THE WORLD HAS
BECOME MORE POLARIZED IN RECENT
YEARS AND THE FEELING OF US
VERSUS
THEM HAS BECOME MORE
EXAGGERATED. RACISM, WHICH HAS
ALWAYS EXISTED IN THIS COUNTRY,
HAS BECOME MORE BLATANT. THE
MURDER AND THE POLICE BRUTALITY
AGAINST SO MANY BLACK
AMERICANS,
AND THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT SENT STRONG
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD THAT
RACISM
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED. RECENT
RISE IN THE HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS HAS SHONE LIGHT ON
THE
UNDERLYING ANTI-ASIAN RACISM
THAT HAS ALSO ALWAYS EXISTED.
THE WORLD SEEMS LIKE A TERRIBLE
PLACE. HOPELESSNESS DESCENDS
UPON US. YET, IN THE MIDST OF
THIS, I ALSO SEE REAL SIGNS OF
HOPE IN SOCIETY. PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER REMAINING SILENT. WE ARE
DEMANDING CHANGE. WE ARE
SPEAKING UP AND SHINING LIGHT
ON
STRUCTURAL RACISMS AND SEXISM,
SO THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE KEPT
AWAY FROM REACHING THE HEIGHTS
THAT THEY'RE CAPABLE OF ARE
GIVEN AN EQUAL CHANCE.
PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN TRUE COURAGE,
POWER AND GENEROSITY FOR
OTHERS.
TODAY, ON YOUR GRADUATION, I
WANT TO CELEBRATE THIS HUMAN
RESILIENCE. OUR ABILITY TO
BRING
ABOUT CHANGE. I WANT TO LEAVE
YOU WITH THREE MESSAGES THAT
HAVE HELPED ME THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE, AND I HOPE WILL HELP
YOURS.
MY FIRST MESSAGE IS THAT IT IS
OKAY TO IGNORE THE NAYSAYERS.
OFTEN, WE ARE GIVEN SOLICITED
OR
UNSOLICITED ADVICE FROM THOSE
WHO ARE IN SENIOR POSITION
ABOUT
THE DIRECTION WE OUGHT TO TAKE.
THEY MAY EVEN HAVE THE BEST
INTENTIONS AT HEART TO TRY TO
PERSUADE US FROM TAKING THE
WRONG STEP THAT WE MIGHT REGRET
LATER. I OFTEN FIND SUCH ADVICE
QUITE USEFUL AND HAVE BENEFITED
FROM MANY OF THEM. HOWEVER, I
HAVE ALSO RECEIVED ADVICE THAT
IF I ALLOWED IT OR IF I
FOLLOWED IT, IT WOULD HAVE
RUINED MY LIFE. IN COLLEGE, I
WAS ADVISED NOT TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN SCIENCE BECAUSE I AM
JUST NOT CUT OUT FOR IT.
I AM SURE MY PROFESSOR HAD THE
BEST INTENTION OF TRYING TO
PERSUADE ME AWAY FROM A
LIFETIME
OF FAILURE AND MISERY, BUT I AM
GLAD I DID NOT TAKE IT.
OF COURSE, ONE CAN ARGUE, THERE
IS
SURVIVORSHIP BIAS IN SUCH AN
ARGUMENT, BUT I OFTEN WONDER
HOW
MANY OTHER GIRLS WERE TOLD THE
SAME ADVICE WHO FOLLOWED IT OR
WHO WERE CRUSHED BY IT AND
NEVER MADE IT IN THEIR DREAM
PROFESSION.
MY SECOND MESSAGE IS TO REFLECT
INTERNALLY ABOUT THE PURPOSE OF
YOUR LIFE. IT SOUNDS SO CLICHÉ
AND I AM SORRY FOR THAT, BUT I
BELIEVE THIS QUESTION WILL
GUIDE
YOU IN THE RIGHT PATH. I
SUSPECT
I WILL GET A VERY DIFFERENT
ANSWER FROM A PHYSICIST AND
A THEOLOGIAN. I AM INSTEAD
TALKING AT THE GROUND LEVEL -
WHAT GIVES EACH ONE OF YOU THE
PURPOSE OR MEANING IN LIFE. AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR
CAREER, INTO YOUR RESPECTIVE
FIELDS OF WORK, LET US CONSIDER
NOT JUST WHAT YOU WANT TO DO
WITH YOUR LIFE, BUT HOW YOU
WANT
TO LIVE IT. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
FORCED ME TO DIG DEEP WITHIN
MYSELF AND ASK, WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF ME BEING HERE ON
EARTH IN THE YEAR 2021?
OVER THE YEARS
I HAVE ASKED THE SAME QUESTION
AND MY ANSWER HAS EVOLVED TO
COALESCE AROUND THE IDEA THAT
THE ULTIMATE PURPOSE OF MY
EXISTENCE DERIVES FROM HOW MUCH
POSITIVE IMPACT I CAN HAVE ON
OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES. IT CAN BE SO
SMALL AS TO BRING A SMILE FOR A
FEW SECONDS, ALL THE WAY TO
SAVING SOMEONE'S LIFE. SO
PLEASE
TAKE SOME TIME TO REFLECT INTO
YOUR OWN INNER SELF AND ASK WHY
YOU
ARE HERE AND HOW YOU WANT TO
IMPACT THIS WORLD.
MY FINAL MESSAGE IS TO PAY IT
FORWARD.
AS A YALE GRADUATE, YOU
ALL HAVE BEEN GIVEN A GIFT OF
TALENT, AMBITION, AND PRIVILEGE
TO PURSUE KNOWLEDGE. LIGHT AND
TRUTH. HOW POWERFUL IS THAT?
HOW
YOU USE THIS GIFT IS ENTIRELY
UP TO YOU. SOMEONE IN YOUR LIFE
HAS SUPPORTED YOU TO GET TO
WHERE YOU ARE TODAY. THAT
SOMEONE MAY BE YOUR FAMILY,
FRIENDS, PARTNER OR A TEACHER.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHILE YOU
ABSOLUTELY DESERVE TO BE
CELEBRATED TODAY, YOUR SUCCESS
WAS NOT ACHIEVED ALONE. WE ALL
OWE IT TO THAT SOMEONE, TO PAY
IT FORWARD - TO LIFT UP THOSE
AROUND US, SO THEY TOO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE
SOMETHING
GREAT. THE AMAZING TRUTH IS
THAT
LIFE IS NOT A ZERO-SUM GAME. WE
CAN ALL WIN TOGETHER. A WIN IS
MORE MEANINGFUL WHEN IT
BENEFITS
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
LET'S BE KIND TO ONE ANOTHER.
LET'S BE GENEROUS. BEING KIND
AND GENEROUS DOES NOT HAVE TO
COME AT THE COST OF EXCELLENCE.
YOU CAN BE ALL OF THESE THINGS.
ON YOUR LIFE'S JOURNEY,
REMEMBER
TO LEND YOUR HANDS TO LIFT UP
OTHERS.
IN CLOSING, I LEAVE YOU WITH MY
GREATEST HOPE. THE HOPE THAT
EACH OF YOU WILL WALK OUT OF
THIS PLACE TO MAKE THIS WORLD A
BETTER PLACE FOR OTHERS. THAT
YOU WILL GIVE VOICE TO THE
VOICELESS. DISCOVER AND
INNOVATE
IN SCIENCE THAT WILL SAVE
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND LIVELIHOOD.
CREATE ART, WRITE A BOOK,
DIRECT
A MOVIE, OR PLAY MUSIC THAT
GIVE
HOPE AND MEANING. BE A LEADER,
AND BUILD A COMMUNITY THAT IS
DIVERSE, RESILIENT AND KIND.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO
YOU ALL!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO
REQUEST THAT PETER SALOVEY
CONFER DEGREES UPON THIS YEAR'S
GRADUATES.
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR
DEGREES IN THE GRADUATE SCHOOL:
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ADVANCED STUDY, SIX IN NUMBER;
SCIENCE, 239 IN NUMBER;
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ARTS, 194 IN NUMBER;
IT'S OKAY.
WE DIDN'T LOSE THREE PEOPLE.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
PHILOSOPHY, 338 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL. WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
CORPORATION I WILL ASK YOU BY
YOUR OFFICIAL ACT  CONFER
UPON
THEM THESE DEGREES.
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGRS IN THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS A
SPONSIBILITIES.
>> BY ADITION, THE PH.D.
DEGREE, THHIGHEST DEGR
OFFERED BY UNIRSITIES, I
COERRED IN LATINT YALE.
AESES CLARISME: CANDIDAT
ADRADUM PHILOSHIAE
DOORIS,
NURO TRES CENTUMONAGINTA ET
SEX TIBI PRAESTO. A FACULTE
PHOSOPHIAE AIUMQUE ET AB
SETU ACADEMICO ILLTRI
APPROBAE
GO
UTOS AD HUNCRADUM ADMITTAS
SECUNDUM LES MOREMQUE
GRADUMHILOSOPHIAE CTORIS D
MITTO, VOBISE UNA CUM HO
DIGNITAT, QUAE AD HUNC
HOREM
ECTANT CONFERONUNC, STUDII
FELITER ABSOLUTI EGO,
PRAESEUNIVERITIS, VOS EX
[  CHEERAND APPLAUSEALERE.
>> SORRY.
VE TO GET MY PAGE AGAIN.
THK YOU, PRESIDENT SALOV.
YOU ON EARNG YOUR DEGRS O
DURING SUCDIFFICULT AND
CHLENGING TIMES.
THE MISSIOOFRADUATE SCOL
IS TTRAIN SCHOLA TO PUSH
THE
BODARIES OF KNOWLEDGE. THI
REQUES A CERTA COMFORT WITH
UNRTAINTY. IS A KEY
ATIBUTE OF A SUCCESSFUL
GRADUATE SDENT; IT IS LEARNED
WHENOU TACKLE FFULT
ESTIONS WITH RIGOR AND
DISCIP
BUT IN THE LAST 14 MONS OR
SO,
YOU HAVE SHOULDERED THE
ADDITIONAL
BURDEN OF BRINGING YOUR WORK TO
FRUITION - SOMEHOW - IN THE
MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC.  IN
ADDITION TO THE MORE CHALLENGES
OF BEING A GRADUATE STUDENT,
YOU
HAVE COPED WITH SITUATIONS WE
NEVER EXPECTED: YOUR OWN
ILLNESS
OR THAT OF FAMILY MEMBERS.
DISRUPTIONS IN YOUR RESEARCH,
AND YOUR ABILITY TO CONDUCT
FIELDWORK. THE STRESS OF DOING
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF EVOLVING
HEALTH AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS,
WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT WOULD BE
THROWN AT YOU NEXT. AND THE
COMPASSIONATE AWARENESS THAT
OTHERS ARE SUFFERING IN GREAT
NUMBERS ALL AROUND US FROM THE
DUAL WEIGHT OF COVID AND
HEIGHTENED AWARENESS OF
INEQUALITY AND RACISM IN OUR
COUNTRY.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT,
DESPITE WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH, YOU HAVE PERSISTED
WITH
GREAT COURAGE TO PURSUE YOUR
RESEARCH AND UPHOLD YOUR
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITIES, ALL
THE WHILE EMBRACING YOUR DUTIES
AS GOOD FRIENDS, NEIGHBORS AND
CITIZENS.
YOU HAVE FOUND, LIKE THOSE WHO
HAVE GONE BEFORE YOU, THAT
GRADUATE SCHOOL IS ABOUT
NEGOTIATING THE FRONTIER OF
WHAT
IS KNOWN AND WHAT IS UNKNOWN.
NOT ONLY
IN THE COURSE OF RESEARCH, BUT
IN LIFE ITSELF. I DON'T THINK
WE
HAVE A SINGLE WORD FOR THAT
LIMINAL STATE, BUT WE COULD
DESCRIBE IT AS A TOLERANCE FOR
AMBIGUITY. WHEN YOU STARTED
GRADUATE SCHOOL SEVERAL YEARS
AGO, YOU MAY REMEMBER MY
TELLING
YOU THAT THE ROMANTIC POET,
JOHN
KEATS, CALLED THIS STATE
"NEGATIVE CAPABILITY," OR THE
CAPACITY TO THRIVE IN THE MIDST
OF UNCERTAINTY AND DOUBT.
KEATS,
AND OTHERS AFTER HIM,
UNDERSTOOD
"NEGATIVE CAPABILITY" AS A
PREREQUISITE FOR DISCOVERY AND
CREATIVITY. AND ALTHOUGH IT MAY
MAY BE DISCOMFITING AT TIMES,
YOU HAVE PROBABLY FOUND THAT TO
BE TRUE FOR YOURSELF AS WELL.
TO BECOME THE SCHOLARS AND
RESEARCHERS YOU ARE AND ASPIRE
TO BE, YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO BE
COMFORTABLE - EVEN EXCITED -
WHEN FACED WITH UNCERTAINTY AND
MYSTERY. TO PUSH FORWARD THE
BOUNDARIES OF WHAT WE KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE WORLD, WE
A BIT UNSETTLED BY IT.
THERE ARE OTHER POWERFUL
COMPETENCIES YOU HAVE - SKILLS
THAT ARE ATTRACTIVE TO
POTENTIAL
EMPLOYERS IN ADDITION TO MAKING
YOU A BETTER RESEARCHER AND AN
INTREPID SEEKER OF KNOWLEDGE.
YOU KNOW HOW TO TAP INTO YOUR
INNATE CURIOSITY AND TO
CONFRONT
COMPLICATED PROBLEMS IN A
SYSTEMATIC WAY. YOU CAN MANAGE
THE TWISTS AND TURNS OF
RESEARCH; WORK WITH OTHERS WHO
MAY HOLD DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
FROM YOUR OWN; AND COMMUNICATE
YOUR IDEAS WITH CLARITY AND
GRACE. YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY A PROBLEM OR AN ISSUE
AND PURSUE IT UNTIL A SOLUTION
IS FOUND, OR KNOWLEDGE IS
GAINED, WITHOUT BEING
DISCOURAGED.
WELL, MOSTLY WITHOUT BEING
AND YOUR SKILLS IN
PROBLEM-SOLVING, EMBRACING
DIFFERENCES, AND BUILDING
CONSTRUCTIVE FRIENDSHIPS WILL
HELP YOU WHEN FACED WITH
THE VICISSITUDES OF WORK AND
PERSONAL LIFE. ANYONE CAN HAVE
A
PASSION FOR AN IDEA OR A
SUBJECT, BUT A GRADUATE STUDENT
LEARNS HOW TO CARRY IT FORWARD
WITH DETERMINATION AND
OPTIMISM.
THIS IS THE VERY REASON A
GRADUATE DEGREE MATTERS, DURING
A PANDEMIC OR ANY OTHER TIME:
OUR UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
CRITICAL INQUIRY, INTELLECTUAL
RIGOR, AND CREATIVE
PROBLEM-SOLVING GIVE US WHAT WE
NEED TO CONFRONT ANY
DIFFICULTY,
ADDRESS ANY UNEXPECTED
DEVELOPMENT. AND THE WORLD
NEEDS
YOU, RIGHT NOW, TO APPLY WHAT
YOU HAVE LEARNED TO THE MOST
INTRACTABLE QUESTIONS AND
PREDICAMENTS OF OUR TIME.
I INVITED PROFESSOR IWASAKI TO
TALK WITH YOU TODAY NOT ONLY
BECAUSE SHE IS AN INSPIRING
SPEAKER, BUT BECAUSE SHE IS AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO USES HER
TRAINING TO ACTIVELY SOLVE A
PROBLEM OF GREAT COMPLEXITY
EVEN
AS IT UNFOLDS.
IT IS TRUE THAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH AN EXTRAORDINARY TIME,
BUT I WISH TO LEAVE YOU WITH
THE
GOOD NEWS THAT YOU ARE IDEALLY
PREPARED TO FACE TODAY'S
CHALLENGES AND ANY THAT MIGHT
ARISE IN FUTURE. YOU CAN WORK
YOUR WAY TOWARD SOLUTIONS USING
THE SKILLS YOU LEARNED HERE AT
YALE.
WE CONFER YOUR DEGREES UPON YOU
IN ALL CONFIDENCE, LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEE WHAT YOU WILL
ACCOMPLISH.
YOU LEAVE
YALE AS THINKERS, EXPLORERS,
CREATORS, AND TEACHERS;
INVENTIVE AND ORIGINAL
SCHOLARS,
LEADERS, AND COMMUNICATORS.
WHATEVER DIRECTION YOU CHOOSE,
LET YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS
INSPIRE
YOU TO TACKLE NEW CHALLENGES
KNOWING YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO CONFRONT THE UNFORESEEN.
IT HAS BEEN MY PRIVILEGE TO
LEAD
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL'S EFFORTS,
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT HELPED YOU
GROW
INTO THE SCHOLARS YOU ARE
TODAY.
I AM HUGELY PROUD OF WHAT YOU
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AND EXCITED
TO
SEE WHAT YOU WILL DO NEXT.
CONGRATULATIONS!
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND NOW TO CLOSE OUR CEREMONY,
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
CHAPLAIN SHARON KUGLER FOR HER
PARTING WORDS TO YOU, AND A
BENEDICTION.
>> AT THE END OF HER WONDERFUL
BOOK, "WINTERING," KATHERINE
MAY
WRITES ABOUT THE ANNUAL GAELIC
FESTIVAL OF IMBOLC WHICH TAKES
PLACE IN EARLY SPRING.  THIS
CELEBRATION INVOLVES DUSTING
AWAY THE COBWEBS AND OTHER
REMNANTS OF THE LONG WINTER
MONTHS AND EXAMINES WHAT IT
TAKES TO EMERGE FROM A
RELENTLESSLY TOUGH SEASON.  A
SEASON REMINISCENT OF GRADUATE
STUDIES WITH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
SUPERIMPOSED OVER IT.
INTELLECTUAL, EMOTIONAL AND
SPIRITUAL LABOR HAS BEEN THE
CONSTANT WITH UNCERTAINTY
DWELLING IN DARK CORNERS.
MAY WRITES ABOUT THE UNFURLING
OF NEW LEAVES AND LEARNING TO
COPE WITH THE DEBRIS OF A
LONG-DISORDERED SEASON.  SHE
GIVES US THIS TO PONDER, "BUT
WE
ARE BRAVE, AND THE NEW WORLD
AWAITS US, GLEAMING AND GREEN,
ALIVE WITH THE BEAT OF WINGS.
AND BESIDES, WE HAVE A KIND OF
GOSPEL TO TELL NOW, AND A DUTY
TO SHARE IT.  WE, WHO HAVE
WINTERED, HAVE LEARNED SOME
THINGS.  WE SING IT OUT LIKE
BIRDS.  WE LET OUR VOICES FILL
THE AIR."
MY BELOVED YALE FAMILY, YOU
HAVE
LEARNED SOME THINGS.  YOU HAVE
DONE IT, AND AT TIMES IT MIGHT
HAVE FELT IMPOSSIBLE, BUT YOU
HAVE CRAWLED THROUGH A LONG
HARD
DISORDERED SEASON.
NOW GO FORTH WITH JOY FOR YOU
HAVE MADE IT.
YOU HAVE A DUTY TO
SHARE WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED, TO
SING IT OUT LIKE BIRDS.
WE TAKE LEAVE OF THIS PLACE
FILLED WITH GRATITUDE FOR OUR
FAMILIES, FRIENDS, TEACHERS AND
GUIDES.  WE ARE MINDFUL OF
THOSE
WE CHERISH WHO ARE NOT HERE AND
WHOSE PRESENCE IS SORELY
MISSED.
TODAY THOUGH, WE ARE HERE, AND
WE ARE ALIVE WITH THE BEAT OF
WINGS.
ON THIS DAY AND EVERY DAY
FORWARD
MAY ALL THAT IS HOLY SHINE UPON
US AND TENDERLY BLESS OUR EVERY
BREATH.
MAY WE GO IN SHALOM, IN SALAAM,
IN SHANTI.
MAY WE GO IN
PEACE.
AMEN
♪